Hello, welcome to this talk on hyperdrive.el.
I'm Joseph Turner, presenting on behalf of Ushen,
a tiny independent information freedom non-profit.
Hyperdrive.el is an EMAX interface
to the Hyperdrive peer-to-peer file sharing system
built by hole punch.
Like other peer-to-peer file sharing tools,
such as BitTorrent, Hyperdrive lets you
share unlimited files directly with other users
without having to go through a central hub.
One thing that sets Hyperdrive apart
is that the files you share can be modified.
And since Hyperdrive has built-in versioning,
you can explore the history of changes
that you make to your files or others make to theirs.
You can stream video and audio.
There's no sign-up or account creation process required,
and it's all free software.
This means that the community has the legal right,
the tools and the information necessary
to participate in the development process,
or even fork the project and go simmer-on.
Since last year's talk, we've added a few new features.
It's now much easier to get started using Hyperdrive.el
since we added the Hyperdrive install command,
which downloads the gateway program
and installs it on your machine.
We added a peer-graph feature, which
lets you visualize your network of sources of information.
We also published a new package, Hyperdrive,
Org Transclusion, which lets you display
live updating snippets of Hyperdrive files in Org documents.
Let's get started.
Let's say you get an email from your friend, Alice,
inviting you to check out Hyperdrive.el.
Let's click on the link here to look at the manual.
Let's go down to the installation section.
So it says you need to have GNU EMAX version 28.1 or later.
I'll assume you have it installed, but if not,
you can click this link.
You need to have curl installed, which is likely already
the case, but if not, Hyperdrive.el will let you know.
Now, from within EMAX, you can install Hyperdrive.el.
Run meta-x, package, refresh contents.
Then meta-x, package install, type in Hyperdrive,
and hit return.
Next, we'll install Hyper Gateway Usher.
Let's run meta-x, Hyperdrive install.
It's prompting me to download and install the gateway,
which is 51 megabytes.
I'll press Y, and I will skip most of the download process.
The download is wrapping up.
Now, it's prompting me to start the gateway.
I can other run meta-x, Hyperdrive start,
or I can press this button.
And after a few moments, we'll see that the gateway will start.
It's ready.
You can also click this button, view Hyperdrive user
info manual, to view the same manual
that we were viewing in the browser.
The info manual comes with Hyperdrive.el
and is available offline.
Now that everything's installed and the gateway is running,
we're back at Alice's email.
Let's click on the link to her Hyperdrive.
Here's Alice's Hyperdrive.
Let's open her hello.org file.
I'm being prompted to mark Alice's Hyperdrive.
Currently, it's unknown.
I'll press question mark to see more details.
Safe, unsafe, unknown, I'll press E for explain.
In the info manual, it says that if a Hyperdrive
is marked as safe, that means files in that Hyperdrive
will automatically have their major mode enabled
based on their file extension.
In this case, if I mark Alice's Hyperdrive as safe,
and I click on this hello.org file, Emax will automatically
enable org mode in that file.
Since I know Alice directly, I'll mark her Hyperdrive as safe.
I'll click on the file hello.org again,
and now I'll press shift S for safe.
Now I'm going to set Alice's pet name.
Hyperdrive.el has different ways to name a Hyperdrive.
The public key is the drive's unique identifier.
You can also assign yourself a public nickname, which
you announce to the world.
Then users on their own machines can assign each Hyperdrive
that they are aware of a private pet name.
So I'll assign Alice a pet name, which
is the way that I will identify Alice just on my own machine.
I'll type in my friend Alice.
Then when I refresh her drive, we
see that it says pet name in the top left.
Now I'll do what she asks, which is to right click on her name
and open her peer graph.
In the context menu, I see a few different actions I can take,
but I'll click on peer graph.
It's prompting me to pick the max hops for sources.
Default three.
I'll choose the default.
Same for blockers.
I'll explain what that means later.
This is Alice's peer graph.
Here, we can see that Alice has two direct sources, Bob and Eve.
Both Bob and Eve have assigned themselves nicknames.
And so we see Bob and Eve here.
Eve has assigned this other Hyperdrive to be a source.
But this other Hyperdrive, whose public key is kb3zr6mq and so on,
if we hover over the Hyperdrive, we'll
see the full public key, has not assigned itself a nickname.
And so we just see the truncated short public key.
Because we've assigned a pet name for Alice,
we see Alice's pet name show up here.
Now I'll open the peer list view to show the same information
in a different way.
Since I'm using a large font, I'll widen this window
so we can see everything going on in the peer list.
We see that the root Hyperdrive is pet name, my friend Alice,
nickname Alice, public key DM1 and so on.
We've set the sources max hops to three, which
means that we will go out at most three hops from Alice
in order to find sources.
So one hop from Alice, our Bob and Eve.
One hop from Eve is kb3, which is two hops from Alice.
Now we've set the max hops for sources to three.
But in this case, the network is small.
And kb3 has no sources.
And so we can only go out two hops from Alice
until we run out of sources.
In the future, we plan to add a search feature
based on this list of sources.
You type in a query, and you get back a list of results
published by Eve, Bob, or kb3.
It's also possible to block peers.
I'll open the transient menu by pressing question mark.
For now, let's turn on showing blocked peers.
So I'll press S, X, and now it says blocked sources.
Now we can see Mallory also shows up.
Mallory has been included as a source by Eve,
but is blocked.
And so in the end result, she does not show up
in the list of sources.
Instead, she shows up as a blocked source.
But how is it that Mallory ended up being blocked?
Let's open up the transient menu once more,
and click S, B to show blockers.
Now we can see that Bob has blocked Mallory.
This means that Bob is not interested in seeing search
results from Mallory.
Since Alice has included Bob as a blocker,
that means that Alice trusts Bob to block people on her behalf.
And so since Bob has blocked Mallory,
Mallory does not show up in Alice's peer graph as a source.
Well, now I'm curious to see what it is Mallory published
that drove Bob to block her.
So I'll right click on Mallory.
And in the context menu, open hyperdrive.
And wingsuit flying grand canyon point of view, not clickbait.
I got to check this out.
No.
Disgusting.
No wonder Bob blocked Mallory.
Let's go back to Alice's peer graph.
So Mallory is a blocked source.
Are there any peers who are blocked, but who aren't sources?
I'll open the transient menu, and I'll press S, X.
Now we're looking at blocked non-sources.
Darth, who's been blocked by Bob,
has not been added by any of Alice's sources as a source.
And so Darth is a blocked non-source.
I'll open the transient menu again, and I'll press S, X.
And now we're looking at all blocked peers.
So both Mallory and Darth show up.
If I scroll down in the peer list,
we'll see that Mallory is listed under blocked sources.
And Darth is listed under blocked non-sources.
This view has gotten a little bit busy.
Let's say that we're only interested in how Alice
relates to Mallory.
So I'll open the transient menu,
and I will filter the graph to show paths only to Mallory.
I'll press O, A, type in Mallory, and hit Enter.
And now we see that Mallory has a bold border.
And KB3 and Darth are missing from the graph.
Eves shows up because there is a path from Alice
to Mallory that goes through E, same for Bob.
We can also add more than one peer in this view.
So I'll press O, A again.
And this time I'll choose Darth.
Now Darth and Mallory have bold borders,
and KB3 is still missing.
We can remove Mallory and Darth one at a time with O, R,
or we can press Ctrl U, the universal prefix argument,
and then O, R to remove both Mallory and Darth from the list.
Now we're back to seeing everybody.
This view of the graph is somewhat simplified
because we're showing only the shortest paths between peers.
If I press Shift S, now we're looking at all paths.
And here we can see that in addition
to going from Alice to Bob as a source directly,
we also go from Alice to Bob through E, as a source.
Let's go back to showing only the shortest paths.
Currently, the max hops for sources and for blockers
is set to three.
Let's see what happens if we set the blockers max hops to zero.
So after the graph reloads, we now see
that Mallory shows up as a source, not as a blocked source.
And this is because Bob, who is one hop away from Alice,
is no longer included as a blocker,
because we've set the blockers max hops to zero.
And since Bob is not a blocker, the fact
that Bob blocks Mallory doesn't factor in.
While Alice is the only one who gets to decide who
her direct sources, blockers, and blocked peers are,
anyone can view Alice's paragraph, tinker
with the sources or blockers max hops,
and use her list of sources to do a search.
Let's see what happens if we set sources max hops to two.
Well, the graph doesn't change because we only ever went out
two hops anyway.
Let's set sources max hops to one.
And now we only see Bob and Eve, since KB3 and Mallory
are two hops out.
Source hops zero.
And now we're left with just Alice.
Now I'd like to create a new hyperdrive and add Alice
as a source.
I'll run MetaX hyperdrive new.
Now it's prompting me for a new hyperdrive seed.
Seed is the string of characters that's
combined with your secret key, which
is generated for you by the gateway program,
in order to create a new public key for this new hyperdrive.
I'll type in Joseph, a new drive.
Now I'll right click on my own name.
And in the context menu, I'll choose set relation from.
From Joseph to Alice as a source.
Now I'll right click on my name again
and click on pier graph.
Max hops, let's say three.
And for blockers as well.
And here's the pier graph from my newly created hyperdrive's
perspective.
Mallory is included as a source.
Three hops from the root.
Let's open the list view.
If we were to mark Alice as a blocker by clicking
on this button in the blocker column next to the pet name
for Alice, then we see that Mallory shows up
as a blocked source.
Only now that Joseph includes Alice as a blocker
does the fact that Bob blocked Mallory take effect.
You can click on another pier to set them
as the root hyperdrive.
I'll click on eith.
Now we're looking at the pier graph from eith's perspective.
This pier graph view has a history.
If I open the transient menu, you'll
see here there's a back and a forward button.
Back is bound to L for left.
If I press L, we're looking at the graph from Joseph's
perspective.
If I press L again, now we're looking at Alice as at the beginning.
I'll press R to go forward, and R again,
and now we're back at eith.
Now I'd like to show you the hyperdrive org
transclusion package we published.
I'll open up the hyperdrive manual
to see how to install it.
Now from here, I'll press M and type in Transclusion
to jump straight to the org transclusion integration
section of the manual.
To summarize, we can install hyperdrive org transclusion
with MetaX, package install, hyperdrive org transclusion.
Then, once this is done, we will copy the following snippet
and add it either to our init.el file,
or in this case, I'll just evaluate it.
Now, hyperdrive org transclusion mode is enabled.
Let's go back to the Hello.org file in Alice's hyperdrive.
I'll right-click on Alice, then click Open Hyperdrive,
and hit Enter on Hello.org.
This time, I'm not prompted to mark Alice's hyperdrive
as safe since we did it already.
I'll navigate to the checkout My Piers heading,
then I'll run MetaX, org store link.
Now, I'll create a new file in my hyperdrive
by running MetaX, hyperdrive find file.
I'll select my hyperdrive, and I'll call this new file
response to Alice.org.
Now, I'll paste in a response that I've written.
I'll go to the bottom, and I will run MetaX, org insert link,
and I'll insert the link that I stored earlier.
As the link description, I'll change it to SNIP it from Alice's hyperdrive file.
And I'll save my hyperdrive file.
Now, to show that the link works, I'll just kill this buffer showing the Hello.org file,
and I'll click on the link.
Now, in addition to linking from my file to the heading in Alice's file,
I'd like to transclude this heading's content in my file.
So I'll go to the link in my file, and run MetaX, org transclusion make from link.
And I'll save my file again.
All that's been added is another link prefixed with this transclude keyword.
To make the transclusion show up in line, I'll run MetaX, org transclusion add.
The content of Alice's file hasn't been copied into mind, it's just being transcluded.
So if I run MetaX, org transclusion, remove, you'll see that the underlying content is still
just the transclude keyword and the link.
Now, some time has passed and Alice has updated her hyperdrive file.
She wrote, "Please add me as a source.
Since the transclude link that I added in my file does not specify a version, it will
always transclude the latest version of Alice's Hello.org file.
So if I run MetaX, org transclusion add once more, we'll see that the latest version
of Alice's file gets transcluded into mind.
Let's say that I want to transclude the previous version of Alice's Hello.org file.
And I don't want my transclusion to change when Alice updates her file.
That's possible too.
I'll go over to her file and run MetaX, hyperdrive, open previous version.
Now when I widen the window a little, we can see in the mode line that this is version
57. For an explanation of what the version numbers mean, check out the last video or the
info manual.
For now, I'll go down to her checkout my peers heading and run MetaX, org store link.
Now in my response to Alice, I'll insert the link.
I'll run org transclusion make from link.
And now there are two transclusions.
The first transclusion will update whenever Alice updates her file and the second transclusion
is pinned to version 57.
That covers hyperdrive install, the peer graph, and hyperdrive org transclusion.
Feel free to check out the hyperdrive.el info manual in the ush and hyperdrive here, or
on the ush.org website.
Thanks to the folks at Supranica, we have a public xmpp group chat you can join either using
an xmpp client or anonymously from your browser.
If you use matrix, there's also a bridge.
Thank you for watching, and thank you to the EMAX comp organizers and all the presenters
who made this wonderful event possible.